cette bactérie microscopiques à plus de
3 milliards d'années
la spiruline est une vieille dame un peu
capricieuse du soleil oui mais pas trop
de l'ombre juste un peu et une des
cultures à 35° l'afrique l'inde où
l'amérique sont ses terres d'origine en
bon spiruline y est dominique guérin à
recréer un véritable écosystème pour son
bien-être
la roue à aubes sert à brasser la
culture afin de reproduire un petit peu
ce qui se passe dans la nature la
maladie dans la nature elles tous avec
dans des lacs très peu profond où on
l'habitude de se poser des flamants
roses certaines variétés de flamants
roses qui avec leurs pattes assure le
brassage et c'est ce qu'on produit et
est roi où est donc parce que la
spiruline a besoin d'être à la peau au
soleil à l'ombre si elle est propre au
soleil on risque d'avoir la sq urines se
sentent pas bien
donc en fait en assurant un brassage on
assure une homogénéité de la culture
une fois récolté filtré à les
transformer
frêche lyophilisée ou déshydratés elle
peut être consommée
mélanger dans un yaourt dilué dans un
jus d'orange
elle dévoile ses qualités de super
aliments elle sert essentiellement à
sauver de la malnutrition de jeunes
enfants les sauver de la mort souvent
dans les pays sous-développés un gramme
de spiruline par jour et par enfant
permettrait de pallier les carences en
vitamine a facteur de cécité les groupe
d'agroalimentaire ne voit pas le
développement de la micro algue d'un bon
oeil
pas assez rentable l'agroalimentaire un
jour ça intéressera certainement
beaucoup à l'inscrire pour le moment ils
voient ça plutôt comme une concurrence
aux produits qu'ils ont en main
actuellement soit de produits
alimentaires existants ou des des
produits synthétisée par la chine ou la
pharmacie pour se développer une île
besoin de terre ou de ressources
importantes notre ancêtre la spiruline
s'inscrit dans une culture raisonnée
tourné vers l'avenir